[Music]
welcome back to all records where we
talk about
whatever we want say we got anthony we
got
my man nadine it's the crypto crew
that's it
it is the does that mean we get to talk
about [ __ ]
crypto oh my god we get to talk about
all this crypto we trust i like the
other thing how many did you get
three oh [ __ ] i only got one this one
holds up six he's like three hold on
do i gotta put on my crypto shop yes
that was the plan did you wear yours
no i didn't i didn't know i was trying
to design one for us
i lost more money than i could buy
shirts so oh you see you can't afford a
shirt you can't put a shirt no you're
like 5x right now yeah i haven't pulled
out there
everything is up though everything's up
how do you [ __ ] that up well i bought
when it was up
okay i got it dude you're like a
basketball baby i am a mascot yeah
me and nadeem um uh we got into this it
was [ __ ] hilarious
right he knew this twitter oracle that
made all these [ __ ] calls on a coin
and i'm just too embarrassed to say what
it is but right now
if i would have stayed in that coin i
would have 3xed it if i just [ __ ]
stayed so he was right the oracle was
right
not at the time he's like it's gonna be
so for example
then no it was like because i know that
they do this right
like those groups what they do is like
like they'll they'll make these calls
because they're in the coin
early right and then when people rush to
[ __ ] buy this [ __ ] then they sell it
yeah the one thing i hate about those
calls i see those memes all the time is
they don't tell you when
so they go oh bitcoin's gonna be a
hundred grand i'm like no [ __ ] but when
next month at the end of the year 2025
you gotta let me know
but the oracle did tell us when and it
didn't [ __ ] happen
oh so he lost it i [ __ ] you there but
because that's
literally the whole market his name was
i think it's a fake name it was like
bazir
fisbrony or something
that sounded so fake already what i love
about it is you guys just found this
random twitter oracle and you're like
he's an
oracle dude and then you're both like
yeah man let's buy something like oh
[ __ ] i hope this oracle [ __ ] pays off
it's even funnier it's even funnier that
because nadine was like yo if i followed
every single one of this dude's moves i
would have had a million dollars right
now i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
dude
who is this and i read it for three
seconds and i dropped 30 g's in here
he was like i'm in did he grab because i
said how much you put in he's like 30
i'm like all right i'll put it 30 let's
go
he's like 30 dollars
[Laughter]
i remember i feel like that was the most
expensive
joke that i've ever made yeah like
it was were you laughing sure
[Laughter]
it sounds like a joke now i get it i'm
pretty sure we've been joking since
2017. that's for sure
we all we're all comedians right yeah
especially in finance
well what is all this [ __ ] at the end of
the day right if you really zoom out
you're like this is so stupid in a way
it's like crypto right yeah of course
all of this yeah it's just a vacuum for
our hard-earned principal cash
because look yes there is technology
behind all this stuff and there's
working use cases all this other [ __ ]
but what ran the hardest the past month
dogecoin
i know right so like you know dude my
dad called me yesterday like just super
seriously hey what are you up to i'm
like
like oh i'm like driving home and he's
like he's like listen
put money in doge i'm like what
what what does he know he was like
he said i have some insider news what's
the insider he's sponsored
he's like
that within the hour of him talking
about oh really yeah i did oh did you
check in you go oh [ __ ] you're right dad
i was like what the [ __ ] i don't want to
give him the satisfaction but how did he
know about who's his insider
he doesn't know anyone maybe it was it
was at 50 cents and it went all the way
down to 20.
and then while he's talking to it it
bounced back up oh this goes to show
though
understanding herd psychology is more
important
than believing in a company when you're
trading well especially these these hype
coins the hype coins are hilarious to
follow like
we're gonna do an article about it later
but there's one called safe moon that
everyone was talking
did you really i'm up so much
i love it no i love it but it's such a
get out of it
dude it's a pure dice roll yeah yeah
it's 100 yeah
i put in like uh just 100 bucks in this
other one yeah uh just because like
everything was like pumping like eight
thousand percent the one that pumped the
hardest one
doge backwards oh my god and that pumped
like eight thousand
you purposely choose the shittiest of
all coins no just because it was like
those meme coins this was
bitcoin backwards yeah and then it's
like all those like
shilling coins or like chilling groups
and i'm like [ __ ] like listening to
them
and then uh so i put a hundred into this
one just seeing like if
if it eight thousand percent it would
have been a [ __ ] on the money yeah eight
hundred thousand and i don't wanna lose
it but safe would seem the realist and
then i put 100 in
and i'm in the telegram group like it's
like a wechat group of all the people
and then um i'm listening to the guy
talking about the owner
it's like a 10 year old kid like telling
people like
he's like telling people don't sell he's
cursing the other people out of the
group for selling
and then like 10 year old kid owns safe
mood no no no no no
i was like he's like a 10 year old why
the [ __ ] did you convince me to get it
he owned some of the companies he wants
uh the 10 year old kid
to create this new coin oh yeah damn
smart ass [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
hilarious what does safe moon do
what doesn't love them
it has yeah it has i don't know the
tokenomics or whatever behind it
love it yeah that's what i love because
you're just like [ __ ] it dude yeah
and why not if you if you're if that's
if you're like hey [ __ ] this money
anyway
yeah i put cause the casino's too far
away it was like exactly
2k into 20k in like two or two half days
did you pull it out no it's down but
it's almost like oh oh it's gonna go
back it's down but it's gonna go right
now it's going back up
because it's hard to get on exchanges
it's getting on the third biggest
exchange in the world
which one's that i don't know who will
be high dance which one's that i don't
know
partial partial crypto stories are the
best guys like me going dude i put in
100k
an omg and went to 300. and then like
where are you at now well it'll drop
back down to 15 000.
but it'll go back up it's going back up
guys trust me yeah yeah yeah
that's the thing about it it's going
back up unless you actually know why i'm
gonna ask you why and if you don't know
why
i'm probably out yeah like that's the
thing like a lot of people were asking
me about omg too they're like
how come you got an omg you're in that
one for so long and i'm like because i
don't know why it's gonna go up anymore
all season and it had the new it was
under new uh new management too
yeah but that's what i mean it's like
because i don't know the fundamentals
behind it like i don't understand why
the technology
would go up because there's no volume on
the on there
how do you choose a coin i look at token
supply
i look at the team behind it what their
use case is
what their competition is like there's a
lot of different ways what they're
trying to do too do you ever
look back and go why did i miss this
dogecoin one because
i felt stupid that i missed it no i
don't fomo on anything
oh like i i was just talking to
everybody i do this thing called crypto
corner i'm meaning
i mean nikki's patreon and everyone's
asking me i'm fumbling about bitcoin i'm
full moon about dogecoin i'm filming
about safe moon
and i don't ever full mom about anything
i only buy red if if something is
is red like if it went down eight
percent or something that's when i buy
it i don't buy it when it's green going
up pumping with everybody else
like there's just some things that
aren't the trick
just two colors so easy when you're a
kid
green go no all right
like it's not that hard but it's so hard
when you get emotional right
because yeah you buy on the way up
everyone buys on the way up yes that's
why everyone's an expert until they're
invested in it you know it's easy to
call the shots when you don't have any
money because the emotional imagine part
is the hard part
and then parties happening you don't
want to miss out and all that kind of
[ __ ]
it's so hard to do but it's also like
when you're up when the cell
well yeah exactly because when i was up
when you told me to get into
omg i got in that night right and then
it just starts pumping like crazy
how much was it 6k to 40k and like
within literally within 10 minutes
what the [ __ ] and i'm like i'm trying
i'm about to sell i'm like it's done
and this [ __ ] red candles [ __ ] back
down to 6k
what the [ __ ] faster goes up faster goes
down i'm like texting steve every second
i'm up 5k up 10k up gate
and then damn that's crazy that was when
six to 40 to six in like like a day
or in like 10 minutes but did you sell
oh my gosh well it it drops
texting steve the whole time he couldn't
leave
[Laughter]
the sell button was you didn't have the
sell button next to you no cause i had
it all in cell limit so i had to execute
the cell limit
oh gotcha that's why traders have all
those screens so they could talk to
their friends on one but still look at
the other ones yeah dude i just got two
screens after you could chat on one
yeah well for a lot of things but yeah
it's
really sick i put one on top of the
other and it's so lit
yeah at barbara when we have like our
meetings i'm literally the only one in
the whole company working
while everyone else is talking about
crypto is that right
and bart's leading the meeting of a
crypto i try not to talk about it
uh but i hear like and going to his desk
or justin or him coming up here
i'm thinking he's going to talk about
work with me he goes to buying more
and it's starting from the boss dude
that's our that's our water cooler talk
yeah
sure dude we gotta go where's g auction
bathroom okay
so
she's in with he does it yeah she just
trusts me to make the moves
oh she believes she believes in it
because she's responsible for everything
else in life
she believes that the marriage is half
the money so yeah
so they just throw the money at bart and
say you better not [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
i'm guessing every partner is a believer
until they [ __ ] it up right
that is true today's video is brought to
you by
babel the number one selling language
app
it is pretty awesome because you have
14 different languages that you can
choose from
i personally don't like learning apps or
any of that stuff
and i think i just gave up on trying to
learn a different language
because like in high school i try to
learn like spanish because i was like oh
i want to meet some latinas and stuff
and then they're like we speak english
full and i'm like well okay well okay i
don't really need to learn spanish
and i try to learn my native tongue of
japanese
but my teacher called my parents and
said joseph needs to go to special
school because he's stupid
and he kicked me out of the class so in
high school i didn't really get to have
the full experience
and i'm not even going to blame my
teacher i just didn't do my homework so
he he
he lost faith in me yeah and it's kind
of right
he is kind of right but um after that it
kind of just traumatized me
in learning like a second language or
whatever
and in apps uh i tried one time
it was this program that they said that
they used to help cia members learn
i hated it yeah i was like i'm not from
the cia i'm not
i'm not trying to learn this crap right
but surprisingly babel was pretty cool
because i was like this is perfect
i'm going to austria and i started
saying well they don't speak australian
in austria they speak german baby
yeah and fortunately they had german in
the app and i was
practicing when i was out there in
vienna like i was trying to
talk to people and i had the app open
and then like they're like we understand
english and i was like [ __ ] damn i
happen again
but the cool thing is i learned a few
german words and i was like yo the cool
thing about the app though is it's not
just like learning words it's like
conversational
yeah and just practically use it you
repeat it
in the in their voice technology they
help you pronounce it and like correct
they correct you in the way that you do
it so it's not just like you're reading
text
and you're listening but you practice
out loud and then they s
they they correct you on how to say it
oh that's it yeah so it helps you make
you sound more like a local
yeah you don't go can i get the burrito
please yeah
you go and then and you say like guten
tag and then they're just like
no the right way is gutentag or
something like that
yeah but i didn't i didn't need it in
austria they spoke english that's tight
but if you're trying to learn a second
language babel is the way to go go to
babel b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com and use the code off the record
to have a special deal right now if you
sign up for three months
they give you another three months for
free so that's six months worth of
language
for the cost of three months that's
babble.com use the code
off the record and tell them that we
sent you thank you guys bubble
bye nicky nicki is a ride or die with me
man i'll tell you what like because even
when
when we were in crypto and then the
whole market tanked and [ __ ]
like i was like i still i'm still buying
because i know why i bought this [ __ ]
to begin with and she and she's just
like all right like every time it was
never like
uh this is kind of dumb or anything like
that because i was like that's awesome
because i've done it before
but you also show the amount of
commitment and passion you have to it
too
yeah yeah you're not just gambling like
i'm gambling
[Laughter]
you're a legend you are a [ __ ]
thousand percent man
i'm just trying to get mine and dash
that too though but that's what that's
that's part of it that's all part of it
but staying in
as far as the long haul i will always be
involved in crypto in some way even when
i cash out
i plan on cashing out 90 of my all my
[ __ ] at the end of this run it's too
easy
the money's too easy why would you not
do it what's the angle for crypto
procurement to take over fiat or like a
call
practical uses of crypto cloning our
entire financial system on the
blockchain
okay everything that exists in our
financial system is being reproduced on
the blockchain in a decentralized way
okay so tell me this so like the whole
point of crypto say like in terms of
um getting rid of like um the middle
event
right yep like fees and all that stuff
there are less fees like that's what i
hear all the time
when i send crypto to someone why does
it charge me way more fees
if i send a thousand dollars yeah i
guess if i set a thousand dollars on ben
would they get a thousand dollars
yeah because it's your first adopter
right this is a new technology
that is being adopted it didn't used to
be that way especially back in like 2017
like ethereum
when it wasn't pumped this much you
could send ethereum transactions like 30
cents
i was doing a long time i spent like
[ __ ] eight g's the other week
yeah he's imagining eight grand on
shipping
yeah that's what he did i still came up
though okay but [ __ ]
but you're shipping like through the
internet like it's an email
i know right it's crazy but i i wanted
to make the trade dude [ __ ] so i i did
the trade and i was like ah
[ __ ] that's eight grand right there bro
damn well i was moving like 150 grand so
if you look at the i guess the
percentage you know it's it's a small
percentage but like
it's still a lot of [ __ ] money dude
that's a lot of money so as they work on
this [ __ ]
and the reason why it's funny is i
didn't have to do that that's why
that is what's amazing about it i could
have spent 50 cents on it bro on [ __ ]
good old tara got it cheaper i don't um
but but that's what i mean by the entire
like you're
a first adopter yeah like back when
blu-ray came out right and everyone's
getting blu-ray players they were only
for the rich
like it was like two thousand dollars a
blu-ray player and everyone's like what
the [ __ ] you talking about now everyone
has one if you have an xbox or anything
and the price went down down down yeah
so it's just a new tech that's as it
gets better and
more iterations of it happen it gets
cheaper to use i'm excited that there's
like the whole block fight i mean not a
block like bitcoin crypto stuff
that's uh converting into like
mainstream use like the block fly card
i was reading about it the other day and
then it does give you rewards so instead
of just having like a regular
oh you pump gas you get three extra
rollers you get actual bitcoin rewards
1.5 they're making it out of metal like
they're really trying to elevate and
make it like this cool thing
so it is like the two worlds eventually
colliding
i mean it's the exchanges that are
charging the fees
right it's not like how much it actually
costs just to send an ethereum if you
come up with the technology yourself
well well it depends because if he's
just doing an on chain like
like an erc20 token transaction on the
blockchain then it is really [ __ ]
expensive but the
but the exchanges charge you too because
it's so expensive so what
because i always say like i feel like
for bitcoin at least right now
it's closest i mean it's an all-time
high right but they start going pretty
low these days
yeah that's because of biden right well
yeah yeah
because of the last fifteen percent well
it takes effect crypto
crates news well the announcement was
that it'll be a 40
cap gains tax i guess 39.6 percent wait
so why do people [ __ ] sell because
that's going to trigger the tax
no they sell before it passes through to
like yeah
this is what i plan on doing so a lot of
people stocks and crypto just like
liquidate i ain't trying to pay that tax
there was like 150 like billion dollars
that left like the the market cap
after that news and all it takes is a
chain reaction because everyone's over
leveraged into
long positions right so they they're
betting that it's gonna go
like way more higher right so it's a bet
if that if they're right then their bet
pays out right
or there's a lot less people shorting so
that's what all the whales know
and they basically placed a bet saying
it's going to go
down and then biden comes out with that
announcement
some people start to sell and triggers a
cascading effect liquidates the lungs
and pays the shorters
it's a whole game man that's that's
people see that going down and people
get scared biting gets their cut
and gets this cut you know what i mean
yeah
in terms of crypto well they just want
to tax they just want to tax more
for for um cap gains so anybody who
makes over a million dollars a year or
something like that 20
long term but also i think he's
specifically named like cryptocurrency
so he's trying to get after it he's
going against crypto uh i think
i think he said like bitcoin like people
that make money on it so it's like
like he knows that that's like becoming
huge so he's like i want my share
or government and he talked about
dogecoin specifically
dude there's a picture of it on the
slideshow what the [ __ ] is she
muck he said send me dogecoin
elon musk has i think the most amount of
dogecoin really
yeah isn't it like him and snoop dogg or
something like that well it's i think
it's uh
him and then there's a group of people
that have
the next biggest percentage did you hear
that mark cuban
so i guess in the dallas mavericks
mavericks store
you can buy clothes and all that stuff
with dogecoin
like all the ticket sales are going to
be through dogecoin or something in the
future too like he wants to actually use
dogecoin
for his mavericks why doja instead of
bitcoin or ethereum or
because he's already a billionaire it's
funny i think it's like yeah and then
you found
he found it early it's still so early oh
yeah but i'm like how does something
with no like
no market oh what do you call it
unlimited supply
keep going up bro that's the whole thing
i mean that's it's a meme coin that's
what i'm saying when i
when i ask like why i mean it's cheap to
use are you in it
no but i will i will probably get pick
up some doge really
i actually will yeah i mean just for the
[ __ ] for
i own gamestop for the [ __ ] why
wouldn't i own doge
it's basically gamestop on the
blockchain like in my opinion so
why wouldn't i get involved can we start
our own like jk show group
what's chill mean i think we just start
all like boomers the pump and dump group
yeah
we could have with [ __ ] omg dude with
the money that we had
and then the supply was so low dude why
didn't we do it
because it's illegal
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
yeah well that's why you got to make
like a twitter oracle handle that's like
clearly something else but
not not georges takawa no it could have
been like
jason jo of agrabah
joe of agrabah yeah that would
definitely throw me
i would trust that yeah joel agrabah has
a mysticism behind it
i might invest in that joe of a bitcoin
but then he's also been promoting
mushroom farm on there
then you're gonna know then you're gonna
know [ __ ] you're also some group that
i'm not familiar with
you mean a mushroom farm token oh
i wouldn't even be surprised if that
exists already mushroom farm token
there's so many tokens there's a million
because there's
you can farm a lot of these tokens
farming so saying mushroom farm token
i bet it exists damn what is farming a
mushroom farm
coin farming is collecting a yield it's
almost like staking right but you're
you're pic you're
it's just another word for that you got
it yeah damn
dude farming is this all this stuff is
complicated i just want to know where to
put my money so at 10 x's
safely that's where i'll try to figure
out safe movement safe mode
it's in the name it's safely going to
the moon that's the whole thing
literally in the have you seen the
picture where it's like going to the
moon
but earth is here and the moon's down
here it goes down
that's so good i [ __ ] love crypto
means dude
it's the funniest place in the united
states
but cuban also said that the mavs will
not be selling any dogecoin they're
holding it
yeah really wow they're just collecting
it will tesla do the same with bitcoin
so that's my whole thing so if i'm
paying in bitcoin
right if i go there say it's like 60k
for a tesla right
it's literally like 69 420 for a tesla
right yeah
um and then say that's the exact price
of bitcoin and i go and buy i put the
transaction
and then bitcoin juice shoots up or
shoots down
does that price immediately change or
what do we agree on
69 420. so it's however much that is in
bitcoin at that current market value
yeah
the like say it says like one point
something bitcoin is that constantly
changing right before i swipe
it yeah probably you think that's how
it's gonna work guaranteed probably yeah
yeah yeah it depends on
if they're listing the price in usd or
as bitcoin if it's charging what bitcoin
then that's how they're viewing whatever
price oracle they're using which
the price oracle feeds the information
like the pricing information
like from the blockchain or to the
blockchain yeah that would be reflected
like one of our graphic designers for
barbell is actually in the uk
and then since he charges us by the
pound sometimes
in a month it's like we pay him more and
then sometimes in the month you pay him
less but it doesn't matter
to him he's just getting his pounds that
he wants yeah
that's crazy so let's go over this again
buy safe moon buy dogecoin buy high sell
low that's right
gamestop is not a bad one too and hotel
forever yeah if you like 10x
definitely wait until it like goes back
down yeah that's right well
safewood's kind of down right now yeah
we're down about that yeah
make sure you buy high sell low buy sell
low
that is the number one rule buy high
sell low also when you're
up make a tick tock video about how
you're up and how everyone else
is a dumb ass it's a dumb ass yeah yes
and how you just [ __ ] made it and but
don't sell
regardless if you bought the coin or not
that's like that's how i found safe food
from tick-tock
dude i saw some videos that we're making
i'll show you guys soon
we're gonna do a whole article about it
[ __ ] made me bust a [ __ ] gut dude
gut and nut rhyme so i didn't know where
that was gonna go yeah yeah
i got good i was busting nuts
[Music]
[Music]
you